the rookie with uh nathan fillion how
how much do you enjoy doing that
that was interesting i love nathan uh
he's been a friend for a while and and
he called up and said uh during the
middle of the pandemic said hey would
you like a job i said yes
uh that's not what he said but that's
that's what i received um and they said
oh it's this you know i'd love to have
you come on this is you know
nice arc on on our show
we want to play against type
um
it's this cop who we kind of think is an
okay guy but then
he's he's a
pretty racist uh police officer and we
we realize you know this you know
through the course of his arc i said
well let me think about that
um and i thought you know this is of the
moment it's something uh top of it needs
to be talked about and discussed and
that's what i want you know when i'm
sometimes sometimes you play characters
that are just fun
and it's just to give people an escape
from their day and sometimes you play
stuff that is important for the social
moving the social uh
peak pandemic like
face shields masks testing three times a
week
you can't even
really hard to meet anybody and to have
create that camaraderie on set which i
so much appreciate right that's one of
my favorite things about being on set is
creating that film family
tv family so it took longer to kind of
initiate that or to to to grow that but
uh all the
great cast and crew and had a lot of fun
working with all